- Yall looks so beautiful.
- You look beautiful.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh!
You're so young to be killing it already.
(girls laughing)
That's so great.
That's so exciting.
So,` you play sisters in the movie,
obviously we just saw which
that line was amazing.
But do you guys feel like
you're kind of sisters
cause you had to play sisters for so long?
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] You just answered in unison.
- Right, yeah.
- No, yeah.
We're really close.
I mean, I think what I love
so much is kind of like
the shutdown gave us time to get closer.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's awesome.
- So, when we saw each other again,
we were just so excited to see each other.
Now we're closer as ever.
- Oh, that's so cool.
It's also cool to like
have someone your age
in the same industry and
just kind of bounce off
of each other if you're having a hard time
or good times or whatever.
That's really cool.
So keep that.
Will Smith plays your dad, was that crazy?
Like, were you nervous to meet him?
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that every
answer will be in unison.
(girls laughter)
- I know.
That's just how we naturally
talk when we're together.
But yeah, I was definitely
nervous meeting Mr. Will.
He's The Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air, you know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I grew up watching.
- [kelly] Philadelphia, born and raised.
- Right.
- On the playground.
Where you spent most of your days.
Yeah, it's crazy.
No, it is a crazy thing.
And he's done so many films and he's had,
it's just such an amazing career.
I just can't imagine being so young
and then being around or even my age,
being around someone
like that and being like,
oh my God, you've done
so many amazing things.
You're such a great actor.
- I mean, he's been pretty phenomenal.
- No, yeah.
- Just like you said, despite
he has so much success,
but despite that he's so humble.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he seems genuinely cool.
- And so kind, you know.
When you speak to him
it's just like speaking
to any normal person.
- Yeah.
And he has the best shoe game.
- [Kelly] Best shoe game?
- The best shoe game I've ever seen ever.
- I Love that.
Like shoe game as in like Nike's,
like that kind of like sneakers?
I love sneakers.
- I mean, its like Nike's,
its like air Jordan ones.
And he doesn't tie his shoes.
Like that's his thing.
He doesn't tie his shoes.
He doesn't want to.
- That's just like trying
to break your ankle.
That's just dangerous is what that is.
I love sneakers.
That's my whole closet.
This is not what I look
like in my off time.
This is not, this is all fake news.
So how, you gotta be honest to me,
like how were Will Smith's tennis skills?
Oh, your eyes.
(Kelly laughing)
You were like, so.
Wait, don't y'all usually
have to like for films,
have to like really go hardcore,
like in like practice
for what you're doing?
Oh, so y'all did he didn't.
- So we did.
We did some very intense tennis training,
but Mr Will did not.
And that's mostly because
Richard didn't play.
He didn't know how to play tennis.
He kind of taught himself in order
to teach Serena and Venus.
He had really no experience
with the sport until he decided
that he felt that would
be best for his girls.
So Mr. Will did not
train as much as we did.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's like still respectful
cause you're calling him Mr. Will.
It's awesome, it's nice.
It's nice.
- Yeah.
It was a lot of fun playing with him
because I feel like it made us feel like
we were so good because, you know.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- You can't hear that enough.
Amazing.
Wait, that's amazing.
So wait, the movie is about
Serena and Venus' childhood.
Right?
- [Saniyya] Yes.
It's basically, you see them
when they're around nine and 10
and how they started and
how much they love tennis.
And their father was just
their biggest cheerleader
and the family, you know,
aspect, and you get to see everybody
and just why they do what they do
and why they're so humble
at such a young age.
It's a beautiful story.
And you get to see just the
evolution in their tennis
and how they become little
girls to young women.
- [Kelly] So did they give you any advice?
Like playing them?
(Saniyaa laughs)
- Honestly, honestly,
not really.
They didn't really tell us anything.
Like they were like, they weren't like,
oh, here's some advice.
Really.
I think the way we learn most about them
was just watching them and
how they work together.
They actually surprised us onset.
They like showed up and we had no clue
that they were gonna be there,
which was very scary.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But no, we love them a lot.
And so I think just watching them interact
with each other and how
much they love each other,
that helped us a lot as actresses.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Beautiful.